That's since our table is complete
We can search or qualify
In the first second and third
What's the kwartil
So let's find now
ahmm
First quarter
So
The formula we use is this
This formula is what
Then for us to find where
Class limit
With our first quad tile
First we will find the
km value
Over four
He will teach us where to be with
Or in which class
Limited with quad tile one
So we have to find the first
Value of k and over four
Ma'am always
Ash it's clear
Or is he always the first to be found
Opo he is always the first to look for k and over
Four
We will only subsecute the
Ah's value
k n or b for
ahmm what are we just going to subsecute
So we are looking for the
Quartal one b is
Value of k i
And the n is this twenty six
Again what is
Value of k
One why is it one room because we are looking for one
What depends on what room we are looking for
That's the one
The value of our k
The value of our n
It's twenty six because twenty six are
Total number of
Frequency
Divided by
Four because we are still in cuartile when
That's a desire
Divided by ten
That's what
So let's just subsecute what's given
Ah the one
values letter
One time
Twenty six
Divided
By four
So one time
Twenty six is
Twenty six
Divided by
Four will give you six point five
What about
So six point five we will look here for less than
Community
Frequency
So
Six point five is between nine and
Three
and
Since he was between nine and three
Remember that we will always choose the bigger one
It is forbidden to
Settle for less
Always
Ash look for something bigger
More what
Char so anyway
So that's it
Always between nine and three
The six point five
Since nine and
Three we will choose nine
The bigger number is always
What are we taking is a bigger number
Then when we get that we can find the
All that value is lower
boundary
Neither clings
Frequency before
It's dough
Neither
Frequency and interval
What about
So
Here we are
Our k n over four earlier was six point five
好的
Then
Our lower
boundary
Oh nasan the lower
This is the lower
What is the counterpart
Here's what
So the lower
boundary
Is eighty
Two points
Five
So important
Ash let's see where
With the quartil we are looking for
Because of that
We will base
of values
So eighty two point five
That's our cliffhanger
Frequency before
Before these nine were shocked
Because his frequency is nine
Before nine who is the number
Si
It's okay
Three what again
Minus community
Frequency before
The community
Of class eighty three to eighty five is nine
But before nine who is the number
Three
Therefore the
Community
The one paid is new
It is equal to
Three
Then
Ours
Frequency oh where is the
This is the
Frequency
The
Frequency of our data is
Six so we just put it there
Frequency of quartel one is six
Then ours
Interval
Here's what we are
It's already there
equal to
Three
Let's review km again
Over four is six point five here's it
The one we computed first
The lower
boundary
Here's the opposite
That's lower
boundary
When our class
It's okay
Then the
Community
Frequency is
Three why three
Before the nine who is the number
Three
Then
This is the frequency of our quad tile one
His frequency is so six
The interval
is
Three okay
Now let's just subsecute that in
Formula of
Quartal of course
So here's the one
The quartal formula let's subsecute him there
So I just put the lower
Boundary is eighty two point five k
And over four is six point five
Community
Frequency is three
The
Frequency is six
The interval is
Three okay
So femdas rule us
Prioritize what is within
Parents
So six points five minus
Three will give you
Three point five
Then three point five
Divided by six
It will be
Just on my decimal number
Zero point five
Eight three
The best one at least
Three decimals
Places are used during
The competition
Just round up at the end
In the final answer of two ah digits
But in
Along the
Competition
It is best that we use three or four
Decimal places
What is so
Zero point five eight
Three times
Three will be
One point seven forty nine
Plus eighty two point five will give you
Eighty four point two
Four nine
Therefore the
Value of our room
One is eighty four points
Two forty nine or eighty four points
Two